so here is the program page and i wanted
to discuss with you all the syllabus of
the precision medicine program that
we'll be going through in the next
sessions and also how to register
yourself if you have not done so uh till
now this was the first session where we
thought of inviting all the interested
participants of the program so that you
know how
the sessions would be conducted
and because it was an introductory
session today we did not want to
overwhelm you so we kept it a short and
light
and this is the program page i'll share
the link in the chat box with all of you
when you scroll down you can find the
sessions shared view okay so we have
listed here all the topics that we would
be covering for each and every session
uh on like all the topics here we have
listed so today we discussed about
introduction to bioinformatics or
precision medicine
next we are going to talk about the
advancements in precision medicine and
then we'll talk about genomic data
analysis
next we will discuss oncology data
resources uh that would include raw data
and public databases
after that we are going to talk about
the transcriptomic data analysis aspect
for precision medicine
and then we will talk about health
wellness and ethical concerns
next we will discuss in the next session
we will discuss about pharyngeal
analysis and multiple sequence alignment
and then talk about host response to
infections
we'll also discuss about precision
medicine for neuroscience and finally
metagenomic data analysis so we have
covered a whole range of topics here for
various omix data analysis in the field
of precision medicine and here we have
listed the topics that that would be
covered in each and every session
now a point to be noted here is that all
the program participants will be able to
access the
session recordings here on the program
page itself
we'll upload the session recording here
on the program page once the session is
over
and you can see the recording here under
each and every session also each and
every session of the program will be
supplemented with some coursework
associated online resources that you
will be supposed to go through and
complete
once you go through the recording and
also complete the associated resources
next you are supposed to click on on the
complete session button and you have to
do the same for each and every session
this way you will be able to get a
certificate
so i'll just very briefly take you to
the profile and certification tab as
well and answer the questions related to
uh certification and how do we get it
all the resources that are covered etc
before i do that i would just very
shortly like to discuss the registration
steps so we have
three different subscription types that
the
interested user can pick from
one is for 45 days another one is for 16
days and the third one is for 90 days
now uh obviously as the days are
mentioned you will get the access to the
program
the resources that includes the
omnithargic known portal all the courses
out there and also the divide for server
transfer analysis uh
platform
you'll get the access to all of these
resources for
45 days if you uh pick the first option
and also we have tried to mention the
other uh resources that you will get the
access to
and if you pick uh the access for 60
days then you will also get to work on
your research proposal for the work on a
research project um after you're done
after you are done with your training
for the program
and the license type that you will get
on the t by info server would be that of
an educational license and you'll be
allowed to uh also meet the experts in
one-on-one sessions and next we have the
90 days of the subscription level
where you will
also work on a research project
alongside your training part so once the
training is complete you will work on
your research project and to work on
your research project you will have a
research license on the d bio info
server where you will be able to uh
extract data from various big data
repositories and then upload that data
after preparing it on the t bind for
server and do your own analysis get your
results and that way you will be able to
work on your own independent research
project under mental guidance so that is
the difference between three these three
different types of subscription levels
that are possible for you to
uh become a part of the program
with and
i would now like to share the link to
the scholarship form
so those who are interested to avail a
scholarship on this program please fill
out this form
i will also put the link in the chat box
please fill out the form on the
scholarship page here our team will
review your
application and then get back to you on
this once you have filled the form
please let us know you can also email us
at
marketing fine product
by your marketing as a on project.com
for uh
any further question so that was it now
going back to the page where if anyone
has any questions regarding
registration that we just discussed or
scholarship form please put it in the
chat so that we can discuss that now